thanksgiving approaching almost a week
away there are concerns that college
students all around the country
could unknowingly bring the coronavirus
home to their families and their
communities
laura podesta has more
[Music]
there are a lot of things that i wish
that i could be doing
this semester stella piasecki is making
the best of her sophomore year at
skidmore college and says she and her
friends are trying to stay
safe during the pandemic students are
also tested regularly for kovid
i definitely feel a lot more comfortable
knowing that everyone is getting tested
once a week with thanksgiving almost
here experts are concerned as college
students plan to come home
research shows more than half of
transmissions in the u.s are from young
asymptomatic people dr david paul teal
is with the yale school of public health
what we don't want to have happen is for
thanksgiving to be an event
where a whole bunch of silent spreaders
ticking time bombs
get unleashed on the nation's airports
and train stations
and thanksgiving dining tables
preventing that from happening
varies from college to college some
require
tests offer voluntary tests or just rely
on quick
symptom checks schools like temple
university are offering free testing
this week if i am positive i won't be
going home so
i wanted to get tested as soon as
possible some colleges will have
students finish the semester remotely
others will bring students back after
the holiday which could be risky
stella's mom is glad her daughter takes
the pandemic seriously
i totally trust her and i know what she
and her friends are
doing so i was pretty hopeful up until
earlier today that a very small
thanksgiving with just
me and my three kids might actually
happen
stella was just notified she had contact
with someone who tested positive for
kovid
they told me that i need to be in
quarantine
starting today she'll be tested later
this week
and hope she can get home soon laura
podesta cbs
news